can i be a little bit optimistic though
because you know we do we do get a new
england um a little bit optimism
we're gonna have a good laugh everybody
and and you may think you're up against
this gigantic machine maybe it's like
mechagodzilla do you guys see the new
congress of godzilla or whatever
and then you realize
you know back to michael mouse's point
about these people are really dumb
ladies and gentlemen we have a couple of
gaffes we're gonna start with one you
may have already heard
from fox business biden says americans
earning less than four hundred thousand
dollars will not pay a single penny in
taxes i'm good all right but this guy is
the president and the leader of the
democratic party i'm kind of like okay
you know the machine is like
it's like
rusty yeah there's a bunch of bent
spokes and like steams coming out one
side and you're like oh there's a big
machine but i think it's about to fall
apart
so i did you see this thing from the
forehead so okay my favorite thing about
this is how the media goes he didn't
really mean it was an accident yes whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa spoke how do you
know he misspoke how do you know it was
an accident maybe he's trolling how
messed up is it that all journalists
immediately and most people just just
assume that joe biden is struggling to
speak clearly i have not heard the word
misspoke so many times as i have in the
last two years the word is so overused
right now you ready for the next one oh
boy
biden repeatedly repeatedly says
vaccine.gum
instead of vaccine.gov and ccd instead
of cdc when reading out new covid
website
is it possible
that so for one i think a lot of people
would say that biden is just he's
getting on his in years and he can't
speak properly and he's not all there or
is it possible that
you remember in the debate when he told
people to like turn on the record player
or whatever
for like their kids yeah maybe he just
genuinely doesn't know what dot gov is
and so he's saying dot gum
because he heard someone say it's not
gov dot gov and he goes gum gum i got it
he doesn't know what dot whatever is
well do you remember when he was
supposed to give the number that you
were supposed to text oh gosh yes three
[Laughter]
but then i remember that he's a crooked
you know corrupt politician so i'm kind
of like eh you know it balances itself
out i guess i feel bad because i cause i
can't stand it but then i feel worse
because he's the american president yes
actual trouble on the globe i was saying
what are the other foreign what are they
thinking right now what are they
thinking this guy is out of control but
i you know what i put it out after i saw
that video about the four hundred
thousand you know people not having to
be a taxes you know when he announced
that he was going to run and he said he
went to president obama and told him
about it and president obama's response
was joe you don't have to do this you
don't have to do this i thought that
right there was the red flag that i
needed you know what i mean i think he
was trying to tell him look you can't do
this
uh but the dnc i don't think they really
had anyone else to run because after the
first debate you know kamala did okay
and then she was hitting that one
percent after tulsi gabbard murdered her
basically
yeah here's what here's what i love
is that
the dnc is sitting around and they're
and they're probably like talking like
what do we do to beat trump and the one
consultant goes listen we got a lot of
people who hate trump cnn runs negative
press all the time we can put anybody on
this ticket and they're going to win and
then someone goes what about kamala nope
nope
that's the not her uh how about joe
biden we'll we'll do kamala on the
ticket with him but she can't lead the
ticket she would actually lose out of
all of the like
think about this
kamala harris doesn't win a single
delegate and the dnc thinks you know
they have all the the moderate democrats
booty judge and you know whatever drop
out and endorse biden
biden was the like
milk toast guy that they that they
needed and and the atlantic wrote that
article they said stay alive joe biden
remember this yeah all we need is your
corporeal form yeah wow i'm like
inspiring yeah now you got a guy who who
like the other day he was like i'm gonna
answer questions i'm gonna get in
trouble if i stay any longer yeah get in
trouble with who yeah what are you
talking about you're the president man
that's so creepy yeah yeah i thought
honestly that senator elizabeth warren
was going to try to put up somewhat of a
fight i did too uh and then she just
folded like everybody else i'm so
excited for the day when a president
will do the thing give the address and
then go home and then live stream dinner
with his friends or her friends i don't
care yeah and so it's just a dude and
that's when i said i'll uphold the
constitution
you see him go to his buddy's garage to
play poker and there's like a guy in a
pink polo and khakis with a shirt tucked
in smoking a cigar he goes i love that
part where you said you'd uphold the
constitution brilliant and they all
laugh and then just crack open you know
some champagne yeah something yeah yeah
but uh um i i
i mean one thing i'm excited for and i'm
wondering if you guys you know when do
you think it'll come about
try to not shop their pressure oh yeah
when it what you know when can we get
that trunnion on a shop at a pressure
and some batter character we're in the
midst of it i think so too
i'm afraid yeah acting as planned for
true anonymous pressure can we just like
no but real quick i mean i know that was
funny and everyone laughed but think
about the serious nature of the
president of the united states
literally said truin and nana shabbat
depressure on tv
i listened to that over and over again
to figure out what he was saying i have
no idea
i still don't know true international
cooperation under pressure yeah
okay
but that's like
we're trying to read his mind on this
one yeah what is what is an american
this is what freaks me out about people
who voted for the guy and now don't pay
attention to politics this is why
starship troopers start to like sound
better and better are you familiar with
like starship troopers i kind of know
yes
uh service guarantees citizenship you've
got to serve for two years in some
capacity in order to be able to vote and
i've never i've never actually outright
said like that's the way like a lot of
people have but man when you see people
at a biden rally and biden goes shoot it
on a shop at a pressure and they go
and cheer for it i'm like man
like who thinks it's good that those
people are going to vote
well they got the same thing i think
remember when dr jill biden was at an
event she tried to speak spanish yes
and everyone was like that makes no
sense but they still applauded her and
yeah what did she say
i don't know what she was trying to say
but it was like yes we can or something
yeah it was terrible
[Laughter]
wow
people cheer for it yeah that's why we
have one of these pictures
right right behind ian actually
is one of my uh no to the left
one of my favorite uh uh pieces of
artwork from george alex opolis
it's uh you can see it just to the left
of uh of of ian right there it's joe
biden and a woman hands a little girl to
bite in the little girl is scared and
terrified but everyone around
they're all cheering
biden then opens his gigantic monster
mouth 180 degrees and holds the little
girl over his mouth and everyone's
giving thumbs up
then he eats the he consumes a little
girl then gives a thumbs up what i love
about it is how everyone is celebrating
behind him yes it's ridiculous silly
ginge uh uh what is it uh jinji ido is
that his name like horror-esque nonsense
but what i think is really captured here
is how biden could literally be saying
gibberish and drooling on his mouth and
people are cheering for it he said he
was going to get us bad at cath care and
people started going yay
like
yeah i mean sure at least trump would
say build the wall you understand what
build the wall meant
it's like okay we're not going to get a
big beautiful wall from sea to shining
sea but at least that's a co like a like
there's there's it's a thought it's a
thought you can define words yeah
we it used to be such a
like a like a
threat there was such a threat in the
world and we as the we created this
country to kind of
i mean
solve that at least you saw world war ii
when hitler started
invading poland and things when people
were terrified that the nazi germany was
going to conquer the world it was like
we had to rally
and now we've got this crap
and it's
i'm not i don't want a threat imagine
like so so they
the left says climate change climate
change climate change there was a really
funny post i can't remember who who who
said it but um they were like
kamala harris is going to address the
border crisis and they were like it's
going to be climate change no matter
what and then kamala harris comes out
and says climate change is causing
people to move yeah it's like okay like
i think there there's a there's a we had
a really smart fella on it was one of a
friend of luke's he was a phd
pathologist and he said that there's you
know
insect species collapse there's a very
serious problems we're worried about it
and i'm like i think you know we got to
be careful and protect the environment
and do all these things now imagine
these people are coming out telling us
there's this very serious crisis we have
nine years left and they elect him
i'm like i you know i'm sorry it's very
difficult to take you seriously
when you say we have nine years left
until there's irreparable damage that
will cause you know bring about the end
of days or just you know kill millions
or whatever or billions
and then
this is your guy like the guy he's
batacast care has nothing to do with
climate change what is he even talking
about and then to make it worse you get
like obama buying beachfront property so
i'm like y'all are making it really hard
for me to advocate for this stuff to
like talk about why we should you know
focus on green energy or nuclear
whatever
when they fly in in private jets with
massive mansions and then they're like
the world's gonna end you know greta
tuneburg being like how dare you and aoc
being like you know we only have 12
years here you go everybody joe biden
he's the hero who's gonna save you from
this global catastrophe
okay now hold on now i kind of feel like
they're laughing at us behind our backs
they're like and then i told them we had
nine years left so we put bite in it and
they voted for the guy and then everyone
laughs and they're all like cracking
champagne and then we're sitting there
in our living room's like
so is this it
and what do we do
yeah well it's a tough show but you know
what's so funny uh the president of
honduras was not that funny he actually
came out and said back in 2018 or 19
that
to
stop so many people from fleeing you
know south america if the united states
would just do trade with us
we could create so much more job
opportunity and people wouldn't be
leaving in droves as they are and then
he said if america just did one percent
of their coffee with us
we would retain everyone that's how much
we could do and so he says this at a
conference
and it's on video people i've shared it
and they still are just like climate
change
oh my gosh open the board political
power
political power uh they want political
power um i think cons there's a lot of
conservatives who get it wrong i think
tucker carlson did a segment where he
said that you know the democrats want
the illegal immigrants to come in
because they'll give them citizenship
and then they vote for democrats i don't
i think it's a bit circuitous uh it's
probably you know true in some respect
but it's totally irrelevant
in california lets in illegal immigrants
these people appear on the census and
they get more electoral votes for the
presidency yeah they get more
congressional district seats so the more
it doesn't matter if these people vote
it just means they're going to get more
seats to the federal government and then
the democrats are going to have more
votes to affect the entire country
so we got a problem and i think
i think we're getting really close to
decoupling i don't want to say peaceful
divorce as some have called it but
decoupling right we see now that there's
many different states declaring a second
amendment sanctuary right or uh uh
pro-life sanctuaries california saying
they're a sanctuary state
everybody's just basically giving the
middle finger to the federal government
if that keeps happening that what then
eventually there's no federal government
how long until i don't know texas puts
up borders you know between it and you
know oklahoma or whatever and they're
like we're a sovereign state and we need
borders now i mean we did see
checkpoints from covet already so we're
getting close huh so am i am i crazy for
thinking that these states and these
cities making their own kind of rules
and saying for example are not going to
enforce these gun control laws am i
crazy for thinking that that's a
positive development because somebody
pointed out to me that that's kind of
what happened right before the civil war
which i was like i need to learn more
about that but as far as i can tell
cities and states doing their own thing
seems like a positive like a positive
change right am i crazy kim what do you
think no yeah but you know but at the
same time they're requesting so much
federal
that's funny you know and it's like and
what we were talking about maybe two
years ago trump was saying cutting off
federal funding to california because
they want to be sanctuary i was in my
mind i was kind of like
maybe that's the way to go you know what
i mean like if if they really want to be
sanctuary and just their own little
state in their own little country
basically then just yeah you can't get
federal funding i like the idea of kind
of cutting the federal funding even from
maybe even cities like portland like i
think trump was threatening to do that
as well back in 2020 but i think that's
a good idea just kind of separate it out
a little bit thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you